hola bienvenidos a economía 24 yo soy
daniela blandón comenzamos en américa
latina la crisis del comité 19 ha
beneficiado las ventas de productos
agrícolas hacia la unión europea
no solo por la pandemia un informe del
parlamento europeo dice que también
tiene que ver con que europa
aparentemente está buscando socios
comerciales alternativos por los
aranceles que le ha venido imponiendo
eeuu y es que esta es una relación que a
ambos les conviene
por un lado latinoamerica es el líder
mundial agro exportador y por otro
europa tiene productos con denominación
de origen como vinos o aceites que
pueden comercializar en esta región para
ponerlo en cifras las compras de la
unión europea américa latina entre enero
y abril fueron de más de 10 mil millones
de dólares y crecieron más de 4% los
países que más venden son brasil con
casi una tercera parte le siguen como se
ve en el gráfico argentina chile y
méxico- sólo en este último las ventas
cayeron en el período te mencionamos
pero no todas son buenas noticias la
unión europea prohibió temporalmente la
importación de limones y naranjas de
argentina por la aparición de una plaga
llamada la mancha negra de los cítricos
vamos ahora eeuu porque anunció que
entregará en concepción áreas para
exploración petrolera en alaska
específicamente en el refugio nacional
de vida silvestre del ártico un hábitat
de especies como osos polares y caribú
es que ha estado vedado para
perforaciones durante décadas la idea es
entregar contratos antes de que finalice
este año y de paso también antes de que
finalice la administración de donald
trump pero como siempre sucede en esta
clase de proyectos hay quienes los
defienden y quienes se oponen
el gobernador de alaska michael dan live
anunció que se crearán empleos y se
impulsará la economía pero los los
ecologistas critican la medida como un
regalo a las grandes petroleras que
dañaría el ecosistema y afectaría a los
pueblos nativos para los grandes bancos
tampoco es una inversión atractiva cinco
de los seis más grandes como goldman
sachs wells fargo jaypee morgan citibank
y morgan stanley han dicho que no están
dispuestos a invertir un solo dólar en
un proyecto en esta zona
y nos quedamos en este país porque
recrudeció su ofensiva contra huawei y
anunció dos nuevas medidas la primera
vez que agregó a 38 de sus filiales a su
lista de empresas que según el
presidente de donald trump suponen una
amenaza para la seguridad nacional y la
segunda vez que los principales
productores de chips de europa y asia
que se han desarrollado con tecnología
de eeuu no podrán vender sus productos a
huawei a menos de que washington así lo
autorice todo esto hace parte de una
campaña de la casa blanca para que otros
gobiernos del mundo meten a huawei
argumentando que la información de sus
ciudadanos está en peligro y podría ser
espiada acusaciones de las que huawei ha
negado repetidamente que sean ciertas
nos vamos ahora para chile porque
anuncio un megaplan de obras públicas
por 34 mil millones de dólares hasta
2022 el plan incluye más de 2500
proyectos de infraestructura con los que
busca impulsar la economía del país a
través de la creación de 250 mil empleos
en los próximos dos años al menos eso es
lo que espera el gobierno del presidente
sebastián piñera que especificó que se
van a construir unos 7.500 kilómetros de
carreteras
el objetivo central de este plan
paso a paso chile se recupera es
recuperar el millón 800 mil empleos que
hemos perdido es recuperar los más de
700 mil trabajadores que están hoy día
suspendidos de su relación laboral
y en walls se inició la semana con
signos mixtos hablando de indicadores un
renovado récord en el tecnológico nasdaq
y un standard poor's con ganas de tocar
máximos históricos desde febrero
marcaron esta jornada las bolsas
europeas mantienen dudas sobre los
rebotes de la pandemia
londres y parís subieron ligeramente y
el descenso fue para madrid en américa
latina' resultados dispares en chile
méxico y brasil ni colombia ni argentina
operaron hoy por ser día festivo
las cifras son los 3.680 millones de
dólares que pagará la francesa sanofi
por la estadounidense principio
biopharma en una nueva movida del
mercado farmacéutico en medio de la
pandemia
con esto nos despedimos en economía
sigan ustedes con nuestra programación
[Música]